alors vous êtes attiré par les stars ou
c'est simplement parce que vous voyez
des stars dans votre milieu parce que
finalement elle est toujours été avec
des gens assez connus finale aller
coucher avec moi et pas connu du tout
saïd sur le foyer de la salle à côté
raya de france a oublié mais oui parce
qu'ils n'étaient pas nombreux non
sérieusement je peux vous et excluant
pas ni lenny kravitz yann hamon jean
louis qui arriveront voir il veut venir
voir les voir vers 9 heures histoire
star sait pas c'est comment dire c'est
pas c'est pas une qualité c'est pas non
plus un métier avant d'être star on est
star parce que parce que on fait de la
musique où on écrit des livres où on est
peintre mais les stars de deux
boulangeries où je m'attends quand on
aime quelqu'un et qu'on est attiré par
quelqu'un c'est c'est pour tout ce
qu'ils représentent et l'homme que
j'aime aujourd'hui c'est une star mais
avant d'être une star c'est quelqu'un
qui fait des choses que j'admire
forcément santa jour quelque chose des
cibles c'est pas les yeux des parents
plus parce qu'il avait quand même une
réputation super houleuse mon super
difficile c'est pas quelqu'un c'est
quelqu'un de c'est quelqu'un de juste
qui réagit quand il continue quand tu ne
réagis agressivement comme on a pu voir
ça quelquefois c'est toujours pour une
bonne raison de cas de mêlée raison que
je dans les situations que j'ai vécu ça
n'avance pas mais
mais c'est vrai j'étais avec winona
ryder ou kate moss six pattes et
toujours il était toujours très agressif
et depuis qu'il avait vu il avait calmé
non j'ai pas calmé moi il est il est ni
séquelles mais que c'est là vont bien
mais quand quand il sait coptes ce genre
d'événements sont on en parle dans la
presse on a l'impression que c'est
arrivé 50 fois alors quand juste arrivé
une fois mais comme on le répète 50 fois
l'impression que ça arrive tout le temps
là j'ai un secret non non j'ai joué j'ai
mis ça à quelques fois j'ai même si je
l'avais donc tg rien faire la fête mais
dont tu es sans rien faire donc voilà il
est au pied en tous les cas julien
enfants qui savent être donc lily rose
melody
ça va vous êtes besoin de personnes tous
les trois là tout va bien vous êtes dans
votre maison dans le midi tout ça c'est
calme c'est pourquoi passé ou presque ne
s'agit pas ma route pour sortir ou que
le moteur roubaud a ouvert parce que je
vienne des petits c'est une oeuvre qui
est ce que vous allez vous marier
nous non c'est pas
bravo j'en sais rien on n'en parle pas
vous entendez pas encore on en parle on
en parle pas ça s'est passé pas quelque
chose qui nous dit nous paraît important
pour la fin vous dites je ne suis pas la
meilleure chanteuse du monde je ne suis
pas la meilleure actrice du monde mais
c'est tombé sur moi
des cadeaux du ciel oui moi beaucoup de
cadeau du ciel alors j'ai en même temps
je travaille quand même bien là ça s'est
nourri cette intifada mais j'aime
beaucoup de cadeaux beaucoup de chance